the movie begins in a prestigious
japanese athlete school saitoku one
rainy day a student named fuwa is
standing on the roof he is a kendo major
and is carrying a bag of supplies
alongside a sword suddenly lightning
strikes a massive rock in front of the
school which creates an array of
mysterious energy fua jumps off the
building and levitates because of the
force the scene cuts to a year later fua
disappeared that day and has been
forgotten over time we are introduced to
the protagonist of the film and an
archery major aoi he is the best student
in his class but isn't confident in his
skills because of that reason he hasn't
been able to win any competitions for
himself or for the school aio's
childhood best friend haruka is also his
classmate and is always encouraging him
it is a normal day in saitoku school
when all of a sudden lightning hits the
magical rock for the second time it is
followed by heavy rainfall which
surprises everyone since it was a bright
day some seconds ago soon the kids find
out the droplets of water are actually
warm blood before they comprehend what
is going on hundreds of cicadas emerge
from the soil and fly everywhere then
the buildings around the school
disappear and are replaced by a vast
forest as the football players watch the
forest bewildered a group of samurai in
traditional clothing appear out of the
mist they instantly start slaughtering
the kids one after another boy this
movie took no time to get going chaos
ensues as the samurais spread around the
school and violently kill everyone in
their way aoy and heruka try to save
their lives but are caught by a killer
he manages to cut aoy's palm but before
he lands a second attack kota saves them
kota is aio's friend and the captain of
the kendo club being an experienced
kendo fighter he is the one man who can
survive against the invaders the three
run into a relatively safe classroom
where haruka covers aoi's injury with a
handkerchief they plan to stay there
until it is safe but are quickly
discovered while running away kota
offers to fight the enemy and asks them
to get their weapons from the archery
club aoy and taruka run to the club
while witnessing piles of their
classmates and teachers bodies lying on
the ground aoe is also interested in
japan's history and the heroes of the
past judging by the invader's weapons he
assumes that they're from the time of
the okahazama war the theory is crazy
because it would mean the entire school
has time traveled to the past soon the
surviving students compose themselves
and start fighting back using their
respective areas of expertise the
leaders of different clubs like boxing
fencing and martial arts take initiative
to fight and save others at one point
the battle shifts to the football field
and grows more violent a samurai is
about to kill a girl but is in aoy's
line of attack however he freezes and
haruka saves the girl in the nick of
time she slaps aoy in his face ordering
him to get his act together being
nervous in a simple archery competition
is acceptable but he must learn to
protect a friend in need at any cost
suddenly they are interrupted by the
arrival of a masked warlord named yanata
he orders the kids to surrender the
castle referring to the school kota asks
everyone to keep their ground but there
are too many enemies and too few of them
suddenly the science club throws little
smoke bombs from the rooftop and scares
the ancient soldiers nerds to the rescue
yanata is about to retaliate when an
informer tells him that the army led by
lord matsudaira is approaching the
castle yamada and matsudaira have a
year-long rivalry and yamada knows going
against matsudaira's army will be the
end of his troops hence he calls his
people to retreat but not without
abducting as many survivors as they can
the students try to defend themselves
and their friends but can only protect
some more than a dozen students are
taken hostage while the others can do
nothing but cry after everything calms
down a student checks the school's
surroundings using a drone and sees that
the entire city has vanished the only
building left is their school a while
later lord matsudaira arrives as
expected unlike yamada's troops his
people are not violent but they push the
students into the basketball court for
safety the students start to panic
unaware of where they are and where
their friends have been taken to reduce
their anxiety aoi speaks up since he has
the most knowledge about ancient japan
don't freak out guys we just got warped
to the past and all the danger is real
he reveals that they have somehow
entered the 15th century also known as
the sengoku period the battle of oki
hazama is about to take place which is
the deadliest and most cruel internal
war japan has ever faced to make matters
worse their school seems to be the
epicenter thanks aoe the battle will be
between the oda clan and the imagawa
clan the man who attacked them earlier
yadama was an ally of the oda clan which
would eventually win the battle despite
being outnumbered moreover the man who
is currently holding them hostage
matsudaira was an ally of the imagawa
clan which is said to lose the war even
after losing the war matsudaira will
become one of the three great unifiers
of japan who shapes the country into
what it is today if the students stay in
the school they will get in the middle
of the battle and probably die they
panic and start revolting but kota stops
everyone he reminds them that any
decision taken hastily might put their
lives at risk even before the battle the
smart step would be to allow aoy to form
a plan since he knows exactly how the
battle is going to play out the pressure
of everyone's hopes is too much for aoe
but he remembers what haruka told him
earlier and calms down he and kota
present themselves to matsudaira as the
leaders of their group since they do not
belong to either of the battling clans
matsadyra thinks they are lying and
commands his soldiers to kill them aoi
quickly makes them halt by suggesting
that they work together he knows that
matsudaira's current aim is to deliver
war supplies to a castle of their allies
however the enemy oda force has built
two camps right in front of the castle
to stop its connection with the rest of
the world aoi suggests they attack the
first camp to divert the enemy's
attention while the main troops secretly
transfer the supplies he is sure the
plan will work because he has learned
about it in history books matsudaira
calls him a dork i mean discloses that
the kidnapped students have been hidden
in the same camp so this will not only
be a distraction but also a rescue
mission he agrees to make the deal with
the students and praises aoy for his
quick thinking however aio's people
should be the ones to go on the mission
because matsudaira doesn't want to get
his hands dirty the members of several
clubs bravely volunteer to participate
but they still fall short compared to
the 500 armies of the oda everyone
expects aoy to join but he surprises
them with his cowardice claiming that he
has to stay in the school to find out a
way to return home somewhere else in the
camp the students who were abducted are
thrown into sheds the boys are made to
labor for several hours with no food or
water while the girls are taken
advantage of in the evening the students
light a bonfire on the football field
getting ready for the upcoming battle
haruka tells aoy that he has so much
more potential than he lets on she wants
him to face his fears and come to the
battle for his friends after thinking
about it for a long time aoi gathers
enough courage and agrees in the
following scene he makes an elaborate
plan assigning every student a task that
they are the best in he also picks a
safe spot where they should gather if
they were to be separated for the entire
night the group prepares for the battle
and sets off for the enemy camp in the
morning in the meantime the abducted
students are abused by the ota soldiers
they killed a girl last night after
abusing her for hours and have come to
pick up two more girls suddenly the
emperor of the oda clan nobunaga arrives
and kills his own soldiers claiming that
he doesn't allow animalistic behavior
against women even though they are at
war he is later joined by a soldier
named toyotomi despite being from the
rival clan toyotomi and the emperor will
join hands with matsudaira in the future
and the trio will become the great
unifier of modern day japan they are the
most important characters in the history
of japan and mustn't die in the upcoming
war for history to remain the same
meanwhile in school the students figure
out that time travel was possible
because the lightning that hit the
sacred rock changed its magnetic field
if they are able to hit it again with
the same magnitude there is a chance
they will return to the future yeah that
checks out after finding out that the
next rainfall will occur at midday
tomorrow they begin making lightning
rods a guy from the sports club sets off
to look for the rescue team and inform
them to return before midday however
their plan is ruined when the rescue
team is attacked by the oda troops led
by the last great unifier toyatomi a
fight in zeus and haruka is captured by
the rivals aoy tries to kill them but is
scared that the arrow will hit haruka
instead kota also notices her struggling
and runs to her rescue only to be
stabbed from behind and killed while the
enemies take haruka away aoy shoots for
the first time it stabs a man but they
manage to escape nonetheless aoe is
devastated to his core and blames
himself for his friend's death and
haruka's abduction the rescue team
helplessly runs back to matsudaira's
camp and takes shelter matsudaira later
finds aoy crying beside kota's grave he
promises to make japan peaceful and
starts teaching aio the art of kendo aoe
used to be in the kendo club with kota
long ago he revisits the things he was
taught and practices for the rest of the
night in the meantime haruka is thrown
into the shed with her other friends the
warlord yanata who made the first attack
arrives and is happy to see the
prisoners still alive he takes off his
mask for the first time and reveals that
he is fua the student who jumped into
the rock at the beginning of the film he
is a psychopath who knew about the
sacred stone and its powers he
deliberately used it to enter the 15th
century and change the course of the
entire japanese history with his
knowledge of the past he mocks his
former schoolmates for being naive and
wants to be known as a leader in the
future his principles are cruel and are
sure to make japan a worse place if he
makes changes at such a pivotal time in
history the following morning the rescue
group led by aoy is ready to fight yet
again they are approached by the
informant who reveals that they only
have six hours until the rainfall which
might be their last chance to return
home aoy riles up the troops and
initiates the invasion the group
separates into three teams the first one
is the baseball team which lands a
direct attack on the camp they attack
from a few yards away using flaming
balls which gives them an upper hand the
second team consists of the leaders of
the fencing and karate club their job is
to sneak into the camp and attack from
the inside the last team consists of the
smartest members of the group including
aoi they are the ones who look for their
friends and rescue them while the rest
of the group is distracting the enemies
the baseball team does its best and
fights until the end they ultimately
manage to take control of the area but
most of the group is killed or heavily
injured in the meantime the leader duo
is also surrounded by guards on the
other side of the camp they manage to
kill one skilled swordsman but the other
one kills the leader of the karate club
enraged by his friend's death the
fencing leader rises from the ground and
fights with all his might he is heavily
injured in the end but manages to kill
the rival meanwhile the survivors from
the first team enter the camp and find
two abducted students they are overjoyed
for a few seconds before their beloved
leader of the baseball team is shot with
an arrow knowing that he won't survive
the injury he volunteers to keep the
archers away so the rest of the group
can run to safety somewhere else the
final team with aoy enters the second
barrier and sees that there is still a
horde of enemy soldiers waiting to fight
them their win is almost impossible but
they do not back down and attack the
horde fearlessly they finally reach the
shed and rescue the survivors but haruka
is taken away by two guards aoe follows
them and is surrounded by fua's army
seconds before he is killed matsudaira
arrives with his troops and saves him
the dying battle picks up with their
arrival and the students gain confidence
to fight back harder suddenly fua brings
out a rifle and fires at aoe matsudaira
comes in the way and saves him but is in
turn shot with his last breath he gives
aoe his sword and assigns him to fulfill
his dream of unification his death means
that fua was able to change japanese
history forever since there are only
three hours left to return home aoe asks
haruka to take all the survivors back to
school he plans to stay until he kills
fua and avenges matsudaira's death in
the next scene aoe and fua face each
other while the third unifying leader
toyotomi protects fuwa the man claims
that he doesn't care about the future of
japan and kills toyotomi to make another
major change in the future just because
he can in a final showdown aoi goes
against fua but cannot keep up with his
skills haruka returns to save him when
he is about to be killed but fua injures
her leg asking her to stay away suddenly
aoi gets a vision of everyone that has
died in the war with renewed motivation
he attacks fua and takes his life we see
that toyotomi is not yet dead which
means there is still a chance of history
repeating itself aoe then brings haruka
back to school just before the lightning
hits however he decides to stay in the
past to replace matsudaira and ensure
japan has a bright future he hugs haruka
before wishing her farewell then the
lightning strikes and aoy sets off back
to the past on his horse the scene cuts
to a few weeks later when school is on
its way to normalcy after so much chaos
one day haruka reads an article about
the portrait of young matsudaira being
found in a historical site it is a
portrait of aoi wearing the pattern of
the handkerchief that she used to cover
his wound in the battle in the last clip
she bursts into happy tears proud of aoy
for fulfilling his aim
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching